VISIBLE.
SAY THAT PEOPLE MATTER, FREEDOM
MATTERS.
PEACE MATTERS.
UKRAINE MATTERS.
>> "OUTFRONT" NOW, HE WAS AT ONE
POINT THE TOP OLIGARCH, THE
RICHEST MAN IN RUSSIA, THEN TOOK
PUTIN ON, CHAMPIONING THE
OPPOSITION.
HE ENDED UP IN PRISON FOR TEN
YEARS.
AND HE OBVIOUSLY IS NOT IN
RUSSIA NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
ME.
YOU KNOW, ONE MONTH INTO PUTIN'S
INVASION, AMERICAN OFFICIALS SAY
THAT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH FOOD.
IT DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH FUEL.
THEY HAVE ALL KINDS OF
LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS.
SOLDIERS DON'T EVEN HAVE GLOVES.
THEY'RE SUFFERING FROM
FROSTBITE.
DID YOU EVER IMAGINE THIS
SITUATION?
>> Translator: TRULY, I'M NOT
SURPRISED BUT ON THE OTHER HAND,
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT THE
LEVEL OF THEIR UNPREPAREDNESS
HAS COME AS A GREAT SURPRISE TO
ME.
IN FACT, I WILL SAY IN THE WORDS
OF THE UKRAINIANS IS THAT THEY
ARE HEAVILY HELPED BY THEIR
CORRUPTION.
>> WESTERN OFFICIALS, YOU KNOW,
THEY SAY PUTIN IS FRUSTRATED,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT THE STALL OF HIS
MILITARY AND THAT HE HAS BEEN
LASHING OUT.
I KNOW YOU HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT
PUTIN DISPLAYING WHAT YOU CALLED
SIGNS OF SENILE PARANOIA BUT YOU
DIDN'T THINK HE WAS, YOU KNOW,
CRAZY IN ANY TRADITIONAL SENSE.
HOW DANGEROUS IS HE RIGHT NOW?
>> Translator: WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PUTIN IS
SUFFICIENTLY -- AND YET NOT
SUICIDAL.
HE CAN USE MASS DESTRUCTION
WEAPONS BUT ONLY IF HE KNOWS
THAT HE'LL GO UNPUNISHED.
>> WHEN YOU MENTIONED PRESIDENT
BIDEN, YOU KNOW, HE HAS TALKED
ABOUT THE THREATS.
HE DOESN'T WANT WORLD WAR III.
HE SAYS IT'S A REAL THREAT PUTIN
COULD USE CHEMICAL WEAPONS IN
UKRAINE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE FEARS OF
WHAT HE COULD DO WITH THE
NUCLEAR ARSONAL.
SO FAR, OBVIOUSLY, HE HAS NOT
EVEN USED TECHNICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPON, BUT THERE ARE THESE
FEARS OUT THERE.
DO YOU THINK THAT THEY'RE REAL
FEARS BECAUSE THEY ARE WHAT'S
HOLDING NATO AND THE WEST BACK.
>> Translator: I BELIEVE THAT
ACTUALLY WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW
IS THAT WESTERN LEADERS ARE
REPEATING THE SAME MISTAKE THAT
THEIR PREDECESSORS COMMITTED
YEARS AGO WITH HITLER WHEN
HITLER WAS VERY VULNERABLE BACK
THEN WHEN HE, WHEN HE TRIED TO
INVADE EUROPE AND THAT'S WHAT
HIS ACCOMPLICES DID ADMIT DURING
THE NEWBURGER TRIBUNAL.
HOWEVER, WE KNOW WESTERN LEADERS
KEPT SAYING THEY WERE AFRAID TO
AGGRAVATE HITLER AND THEY
THOUGHT WELL, IF YOU'RE NOT
SHOWING ANY RESISTANCE,
EVENTUALLY HE'LL STOP.
HOWEVER, THAT MISTAKE HAS COST
HUNDRED OF MILLIONS HUMAN LIVES.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF HUMAN
LIVES WERE LOST AND THE SAME
MISTAKE IS BEING COMMITTED NOW.
BUT HE'LL NEVER USE NUCLEAR
UNLESS HE KNOWS HE'S IN SAFETY
AND ONCE HE'S BEEN CONVINCED
THAT YES, WE'RE SAFE, THEN
OBVIOUSLY THAT JUST, THAT JUST
TRIGGERS HIM TOWARDS THAT.
>> SO THE WALL STREET REPORTING
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
SANCTION A RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
HE ULTIMATELY DID NOT BECAUSE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID HOLD
ON.
ZELENSKYY THOUGHT THAT HE COULD
HELP BROKER A PEACE DEAL HERE.
OBVIOUSLY I KNOW YOU AND
ABROMAVICH KNOW EACH OTHER.
I'VE GOT A PICTURE OF YOU ON THE
DAY YOUR COMPANIES ANNOUNCED THE
MEGA MERGER.
DO YOU THINK HE IS THE KIND OF
KEY PERSON THAT ZELENSKYY THINKS
HE IS IN TERMS OF NEGOTIATING A
PEACE SETTLEMENT?
>> Translator: WELL I BELIEVE
THAT ACTUALLY THIS NEGOTIATIONS
ARE SO FAR AND THEY CAN ONLY BE
REAL WHEN PUTIN CAN FEEL THAT HE
HE MIGHT EITHER LOSE IN UKRAINE
OR IF UKRAINE CAPITULATES.
OBVIOUSLY THIS MAY NOT BE
POSSIBLE SO FAR BECAUSE OF
UKRAINE'S COURAGE AND SUPPORT
FROM THE WEST AND ALSO IF THE NO
FLY ZONE IS PROVIDED.
BUT AS OF NOW, FOR SURE, THIS
CANNOT BE FACILITATED WITH THE
HELP OF HIS EFFORTS.
>> DO YOU THINK ABROMOVICH OR
ANYONE ELSE AT THIS POINT, ANY
OTHER OLIGARCH, DESERVES TO NOT
BE SANCTIONED BY THE WEST?
>> Translator: THE WAY I SEE IT
IS QUITE SIMPLE.
OLIGARCHS ARE NOT TRUE OLIGARCHS
IN THAT SENSE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
DO NOT INFLUENCE PUTIN.
THAT'S JUST, PREPOSTEROUS IDEA
IF I MAY SAY SO.
YET THEY ARE PUTIN'S INSTRUMENTS
OF INFLUENCE AND TO SEE FOR REAL
WHO HAS BROKEN THEIR RELATIONS
WITH PUTIN WOULD BE WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY DENOUNCE HIM AND WHEN
THEY ADMIT THAT HE IS A WAR
CRIMINAL AND IF THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN, THAT MEANS T